[Music]
Ziya is that you the never give up
singer stepped out without her signature
wig for Netflix's Ozark peacemakers
event in Los Angeles the 42 year olds
mingled with Jason Bateman looking Gorge
in a simple black look with her own
blonde locks in loose waves a far cry
from her go-to blackened blonde blunt
Bob the Australian singer rarely steps
out in public without her wig I don't
wear this unless it's Cameron's R of
course I only wear this just to try and
maintain a modicum of privacy a decision
she explained on The Late Late Show with
James Corden I was a singer and permant
already for like 10 or 11 years two
mediocre success yeah and I was an
alcoholic and a drug addict and I
sobered up and decided I didn't want to
be an artist anymore because I was
starting to get a little bit famous and
just destabilising in some way so I
thought what doesn't exist in in pop
music at the moment and it was mystery
and in 2015 former Dance Moms star
Maddie Ziegler who stars in many of
Sia's music videos opened up to et about
the side of the singer the public
doesn't get to see she's literally the
sweetest person ever like I should I
feel like I'm just so comfortable with
her every time I'm with her and I never
feel like oh my god I'm hanging out with
a celebrity if you wouldn't have you
would never guess that she's a celebrity
if you didn't like actually no cause
she's the most humble person and so
caring
[Music]
[Applause]